un día después de que el congreso
peruano presentará una moción de
vacancia en su contra el presidente
pedro castillo compareció en la cámara
para defenderse e hizo un balance de su
gobierno dice que este gobierno no tiene
resultados que mostrar
sostiene ligera me dijera mente que no
tenemos rumbo hoy
en el día 231 de mi gestión doy a
conocer al pueblo peruano
algunos de los muchos logros en este
corto tiempo ante esta nueva crisis
política en el país castillo pidió
consenso a la oposición que controla el
congreso que votó por llevar adelante el
pedido de destitución por incapacidad
moral permanente y negó las acusaciones
de corrupción en su contra se ha
pretendido construir un manto de
oscuridad sobre nuestra gestión se
requiere hacer creer a la población
si quieres creer a la población que
estamos inmersos en actos de corrupción
situación que rechazó enérgicamente el
tiempo me dará la razón respecto a su
corto gobierno castillo aseguró haber
tenido un impacto positiva en la nación
destacando sus planes de bienestar y
protección social la gestión de la
pandemia y la reactivación económica
entre otros no obstante el dirigente
también reconoció errores de gestión
durante su mandato pero tildó de
irracional el uso del mecanismo de
destitución en el país aunque los
expertos estiman que es poco probable
que la vacancia de castillo salga
adelante el 28 de marzo se decidirá el
futuro del mandatario de perú